MEETING TO ORDER WELCOME TO
TODAY'S HEARING WE HAVE ONE
BUILT ON THE AGENDA AB FORTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL AND SENATOR GLAZER
AND WE'RE HEARING THIS BILL
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
NINE TEN BECAUSE IT WAS
SUBSTANTIALLY AMENDED AFTER IT
WAS HEARD IN THIS COMMITTEE.
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. LEYVA AYE HERE LATELY
OKAY PRESENT WILL CARE CHIANG
GLAZER HERE MCGUIRE PAN PAN
HERE ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A
QUORUM. MR O'DONNELL PLEASE
BEGIN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB FORTY EIGHTH WHICH
I'M HERE TO PRESENT TODAY
PLACES A FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLAR
PRESCHOOL THROUGH HIGHER
EDUCATION BOND. ON THE MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY BALLOT. THIS BOND
INCLUDES THE FOLLOWING NINE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR PRESCHOOL
THROUGH TWELFTH GRADE. TWO
BILLION DOLLARS FOR COMMUNITY
COLEGES TWO BILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE CSU SYSTEM AND TWO
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE UC
SYSTEM. THE MOST RECENT
AMENDMENTS REFLECT CHANGES
REQUESTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. IN CONSULTATION
WITH THE WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
I LET ME HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF THE
ON THE K. TWELVE SIDE OF
FUNDING FORMULA UNDER CURRENT
LAW THE STATE MATCH IS FIFTY
FIFTY. FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION AND
SIXTY FORTY FOR MODERNIZATION.
UNDER THIS BILL LOWER WEALTH
DISTRICTS AND DISTRICTS WITH
HIGHER INTEREST OF LOW INCOME
FOSTER CARE AN ILL STUDENTS
WILL RECEIVE A HIGH MATCH ON A
SLIDING SCALE BASIS. UP 255%
FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION AND 65%
FOR MODERNIZATION. ASSESSING OR
HOW WE PROCESS THESE
APPLICATIONS UNDER UNDER
CURRENT LAW APPLICATIONS ARE
PROCESS AND FUNDED BASED ON THE
ORDER RECEIVED. UNDER THIS BILL
APPLICATIONS ADDRESSING HEALTH
AND SAFETY ISSUES FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP APPLICATIONS
APPLICATIONS TO REMEDIATE LEAD
IN DRINKING WATER. AND
OVERCROWDED SCHOOLS WILL RE
REVIEWED FIRST. EXPANDED
PROJECTS FOR THE FIRST TIME
STATE BOND FUNDS CAN BE USED TO
CONSTRUCT PRESCHOOL CLASSROOMS
KITCHENS AND SPACE FOR
COUNSELORS AND NURSES VERY
ESSENTIAL I CAN TELL YOU OF MY
HIGH SCHOOL WHERE THE
COUNSELORS WERE. YOU KNOW IN
JUST SUCH A SMALL AROUND IT
JUST WASN'T FUNCTIONAL WAS A
GOOD BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T HAVE A
LOT OF PRIVACY QUITE FRANKLY
THAT A SO OFTEN NEED TO THAT'S
A THAT'S A THAT'S A REASONABLE.
ASK A BONDING CAPACITY THE BILL
JUST THE CAP ON LOCAL BONDING
TO AUGMENT SCHOOL AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IT DISTRICTS ABILITY
TO RAISE LOCAL FUNDS DEVELOPER
FEES UNTIL JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY SIX THIS BILL WAYS FEES
FOR MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
PROJECTS. LOCATED WITHIN A HALF
MILE OF A TRANSIT STOP CALL
TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT M.
REDUCES FEES BY 20% FOR OTHER
MULTI FAMIY HOUSING PROJECTS.
THIS BILL ALSO SUSPENDS LEVEL
THREE FEES WHICH DOUBLES
DEVELOPER FEES WHEN STATE BOND
FUNDS ARE EXHAUSTED UNTIL
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT. I AM AWARE OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CONCERNED WITH THIS
PIECE AND I ARE THERE CONCERNS
BUT IN CONSULTATION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION OVER THIS BILL
WE BELIEVE THIS IS NECESSARY TO
ADDRESS OUR HOUSING NEEDS THIS
WAS A HARD. ONE TO SWALLOW FOR
ME PERSONALLY BUT WE HAVE TO.
GO FORWARD. GRAHAM MAY BE FORTY
EIGHT THAT REMAIN IN THE BILL
INCLUDE ASSISTANCE FOR SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT WILL
ASSISTANCE THE STATE THAT THEY
SO OFTEN NEED TO GET BOND FUND
SO THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO GO
OUT GET. EXPENSIVE CONSULTANTS
EXCEDRIN. TESTING
INTERMEDIATION OF LEAD AND
WATER. DISASTER ASSISTANCE
EXPANDING FINANCIAL HARDSHIPS
C. T. E. AND CHARTERS AND AGAIN
PRESCHOOLS ARE NOT ALLOWED
TODAY BUT AFTER THE PASSAGE OF
THIS MONTH THEY WILL BE
ALLOWABLE EXPENDITURE WITH BOND
MONEY. AND WITH ME NEXT TO ME
IS A SENATOR GLAZER WHO HAS
BEEN A STRONG ADVOCATE FOR
EIGHTY FORTY EIGHT AS WELL. I
THANK YOU MANAGER. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SENATOR. AT EACH
YEAR LEYVA I WANT TO FIRST AT
START BY THANKING. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE NOT
JUST THIS YEAR BUT IN THIS
ENTIRE LEGISLATIVE CAREER. I
APPRECIATED WE APPRECIATE ALL
THE FIGHT THAT HE'S HAD STILL
IN HIM. TO A- TO ADVANCE THAT
OUR BOARD EDUCATIONAL NEEDS IN
THE STATE. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
GOD THE PRO TEM OF THE SENATE
AND HER STAFF WHO WORKED SO
DILIGENTLY ON THIS. SPEAKER THE
ASSEMBLY AND HIS STAFF. WHO
HAVE DONE THE SAME. I CERTAINLY
THE GOVERNOR WHO WAS STEPPED IN.
TO CREATE THIS PARTNERSHIP THAT
WE HAVE A IN THIS BILL THAT'S
BEFORE YOU. AND WE IT WAS NOTED
THAT THE BILL'S BEEN AMENDED
SUBSTANTIALLY AND THAT'S WHY
WE'RE HERE BUT- THIS COMMITTEE
AT YOUR LEYVA NOW YOU'RE AWARE
OF THAT STAFF. HEARD ARE HIGHER
EDUCATION BONTA EARLIER IN THE
YEAR HEARD THE LOWER EDUCATION
BOND. EARLIER IN THE YEAR AND
SO WE HAVE HAD. A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IT AT LEAST
LET ME NOTE ON THE HIGHER
EDUCATION BOND. ONE OF MY CO
AUTHORS IS HERE IN THE
COMMITTEES YOU'RE WELCOME I
APPRECIATE THAT BIPARTISAN
PARTNERS WITH AT. AND IS IT.
THERE'S A VERY IMPORTANT.
CERTAINLY THE EDUCATION
PARTNERS THAT YOU'RE FROM
INTERNET. HAVE BEEN INTERCALL.
THE WORK THAT'S BEEN PUT IN
THIS MEASURE THE SAP BEFORE.
EIGHT SEPARATE. THIS MEASURE IS
IMPORTANT DOWN PAYMENT ON THOSE
NEEDS IS NOT GOING TO. THAT WE
NOW IS THERE EVERY EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM LEVEL. BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT DOWN PAYMENT AND I
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
GLAZER OTHERS IN SUPPORT. COME
ON DOWN. YES PERFECT AIR
POCKETS BLOCK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION HERE TO LEND OUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS MEASURE
NEEDLESS TO SAY THIS IS BEEN A
VERY UNUSUAL PROCESS WE DO WANT
TO EXPRESS THE CONCERNS THAT
WERE RAISED BY A SETTLEMENT
O'DONNELL ABOUT THE DEVELOPER
FEES WE HAVE NOT HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EVALUATE THE
EFFECT THIS WILL HALF AND WE
KNOW THAT THIS WILL FACT
DISTRICTS ON A FULL BASIS AND
WE DID THAT LOOKS LIKE AND WE
KNOW THIS IS GONNA BE A REAL
CONCERN FOR OUR MEMBERS. NOT
ALL OVER MEMBERS PRIMARILY WE
SEE IT IN URBAN AND URBAN AND
THAT'S WHERE YOU SEE A LOT OF
THE GROWTH IS THROUGH MULTI
FAMILY APARTMENT COMPLEXES AND
SO WE'RE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE EFFECT ON BALANCE THE
SUPPORT THAT'S PROVIDED FOR
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
INCREASING FINANCIAL HARDSHIP
ACCESS ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO A
LOT OF OTHER MEMBERS THIS IS
BEEN A REAL CHALLENGE FOR US IN
TAKING THIS POSITION BUT WE
THINK COME ON SUPPORT TO
SUPPORT ANOTHER SCHOOL
FACILITIES BOND. THANK YOU
MANAGERS AND APPLY CONSTANTLY
JUST QUICK USERNAME AND OVER
I'M ACTUALLY VERY OF THE TOPIC
SO MAYBE MONITORING ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS HOW THAT'S A
LITTLE IMPACT ON THE LOCAL TO
PICK SO THAT'S A LEGITIMATE
CONCERN THIS IS RIGHT NOW. A
REAL AND ABOUT OUTSIDE THEIR
HOUSE. GET QUEUE PART THERE
ABOUT JUST CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS ALSO ON BEHALF OF
ACCESS WE ALLOW OUR COMMENTS
WITH C-SPAN WE TRULY APPRECIATE
ALL THE TIME COMMITMENT AND
DEDICATION TO ENSURING THAT OUR
SCHOOLS HAVE ADEQUATE SCHOOL
HOUSING THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MORNING CHER MEMBERS HERE
CLINICS ON BEHALF OF THE SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS VISITATIONS
WRONGLY IN SUPPORT I'M REALLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT GOES
INTO SMALL HERE FOR FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP DISTRICTS ALSO HERE ON
BEHALF OF SAND ADDS THAT.
FAMILY DINO COUNTY DISTRICT
ADVOCATES FOR BETTER SCHOOLS AS
WELL AS THE SUPERINTENDENT IN
THE COUNTIES OF SACRAMENTO AND
SAN DIEGO ALL STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANKS SO MUCH FOR. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING GEN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCE OFFICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK THANK YOU. MORE
MATURE MEMBER SISTER THE AS
ABOUT HALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL IN THE SAY HI
TO. CURRENT AS THE ALLOCATION
BOARD MEMBERS AND STEAM.
MEMBERS OF THE HARDENING
ASSOCIATION BUT IT'S NECESSARY
TO GET A LOT OF PROJECTS UP AND
RUNNING WE ARE VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION WE
ALSO VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
PROJECT BURKE INCENTIVES.
BECAUSE OF OUR LOW. ON TOAST
PARTNER WITH LOCAL SCHOOL THIS
BEFORE YOUR PRINTER CORRECT
THEM WITH CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION CONNECTIONS TO PRE
PRESSURE. AND THAT LEADS TO A
REWARDING CAREERS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY SO WE
THANK YOU FOR THAT. THANK YOU
MUCH. FOR WITH NAME AND. THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT. JEFF
BARKER REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BECAUSE DOLLARS ON THE BEACH
CITY COLLEGE IN PASADENA CITY
COLLEGE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING PATTY
HER ON BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
KARAGANOV. THE COLLEGE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
TERM MEMBERS MARK MCDONALD THEY
HAVE KERN SAN BERNARDINO SAN
FRANCISCO AND YUBA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT I DID JUST
WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY MAN
AND HIS STAFF REAL QUICK FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS LEADERSHIP
REALLY APPRECIATED IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION WE
DO SUPPORT THE BILL WITH SOME
OF THE CONCERNS THAT ON THE
CHAIR MENTIONED. IN THE FOR THE
WORKING WITH YOU GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU. AOSHIMA SAKE OF THE
LOS RIOS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT IN LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANDREA BALL HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS LOOK BORED TO
WORKING TO ENSURE THAT.
SERVICES AND FACILITIES FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
RECOGNIZE THE ROLE OF SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS. THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS JASON MURPHY ON
BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA A VERY LOUD CROWDED
PLEASE BE TODAY'S TRANSPORT
WOULD LIKE THAT THE AUTHOR'S AS
WELL ALL STAFF. THANK YOU. OIL
WITH THE CSU WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND SENATOR
GLAZER TO FOR YOUR WORK ON
HIGHER ED AND WE RETURN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THE CALL RISE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE C. T.
ALLOCATION THANK THE AUTHORS
FOR THEIR WORK IN ASPEN IVAN
THANK YOU THANK YOU. DAVID
NEVIN ON BEHALF OF THE SOUTH
ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
WE'VE ANY OPPOSITION OR ANYBODY
WHO IS UNDECIDED. MORNING
SENATORS RETURNING WORKS AND ON
BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION WHILE WE SUPPORT
THE UNDERLYING PRINCIPLE OF
FUNDING FOR A SCHOOL FACILITIES
I WERE OPPOSED TO THE MEASURE
FOR THE EXACT REASON THAT
MISTER DE AS A MENTIONED. IN
SECTION TWELVE THE
PRIORITIZATION OF UP LA
PROJECTS WE THINK THIS IS A BAD
PUBLIC POLICY FOR REASONS OF
FIRST OF ALL. WE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT OF PRIORITIZATION
BELONGS IN A SCHOOL FACILITIES
MEASURE LIKE THIS. A SECOND
APPEAL ACE DISCRIMINATE THEY
DISCRIMINATE EIGHT AGAINST
APPRENTICES AND- WORKERS AND
CONTRACTORS WHO ARE MERIT SHOP
CONTRACTORS AND EMPLOYEES. OF
HEARD. STUDIES HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THE PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS ACTUALLY INCREASE
SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION COSTS THE
NATIONAL UNIVERSITY STUDY
SUGGESTED THAT PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS INCREASE SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION BY 15222% THUS IF
YOU ARE GIVING THESE PRIORITIES
THOSE DISTRICTS WILL BE ABLE TO
DELIVER LESS FOR THEIR PROJECTS
UNDER PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT.
FOURTH FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
SMALL DISTRICTS IN OF. RURAL
AND SUBURBAN AREAS. EQUALLY
QUALIFIED PROJECTS NOW IN A LOT
WILL LARGE URBAN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO HAVE A PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENT WILL HAVE A
HIGHER PRIORITY. MANY OF THE
DISTRICTS IN YOUR OWN AREAS
WILL BE AT A COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGE WITH LARGE URBAN
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENTS AND FINALLY
WE'RE VERY CONCERNED THAT THE
INCLUSION OF THIS LANGUAGE
WILL. POTENTIALLY DISSUADE
VOTERS FROM APPROVING THE BOND
IN MARCH THEY WILL SEE IT AS
ANOTHER EXAMPLE AS A GIFT TO
SPECIAL INTEREST GROUPS THAT
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION AND SCHOOL
FACILITIES FOR THOSE REASONS WE
ARE OPPOSED THANK YOU SIR. NEXT
IN OPPOSITION OR IN BETWEEN.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS NANCY TRIED ASSISTING
US ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION
FOR ADEQUATE SCHOOL HOUSING
UNFORTUNATELY GIVEN THE TIME
CONSTRAINTS WE WERE NOT ABLE TO
GET TO EITHER A SUPPORT REPOSE
POSITION BUT WE DO HAVE JUST A
VERY BRIEF COMMENTS. WE HAVE TO
BEGIN WITH OUR THANKS FOR TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL AND
HIS STAFF AN EXTRAORDINARY
EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF WORK
THAT'S GONE INTO THIS WE ARE
VERY APPRECIATIVE. THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE SCHOOL
HOUSING IS THE ONLY STATEWIDE
ADVOCACY GROUP DEDICATED TO K.
TWELVE FACILITIES ISSUES WE
HAVE MANY CONCERNS WERE
ADDRESSED IN OUR LETTER WE WILL
TAKE UP YOUR TIME GETTING INTO
THOSE NOW EXCEPT TO SAY. WE DO
HOPE THAT THEY WILL BE
ADDRESSED AND FOLLOW UP
LEGISLATION OR REGULATIONS THE
PARTY TO ONE ADDRESSES THE
DEVELOPER FEE PROHIBITION AND
REDUCTION WHICH HAS BEEN
REJECTED MULTIPLE TIMES BY THE
HOUSING AND GOVERNMENTAL
FINANCED COMMITTEES IN BOTH THE
ASSEMBLY AND LEGISLATURE. OF
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CAN NOT FUND CAPITAL
PROJECTS WITHOUT THE SOURCE OF
FUNDING SO WE'RE VERY
ENCOURAGED BY THE AUTHORED BY
MR O'DONNELL'S I'M COMMITMENT
TO CONTINUE TO FOLLOW AND
MONITOR THAT ISSUE. AND THE
CASH BOARD WILL DETERMINE
WHETHER AND TO WHAT EXTENT IT
REMAINS INVOLVED WITH THIS BOND
BUT UNFORTUNATELY IT CAN'T DO
THAT BEFORE. THE END OF SESSION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT.
EARNING REBEKAH CURLY ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACILITY COALITION AND THE
COUNTY SCHOOL FACILITIES
CONSORTIUM. WERE IN A SIMILAR
POSITION TO VOTE PRIOR WITNESS.
WE HAVE NOT HAD THE TIME TO
FULLY THAT AND ANALYZE THE
IMPACT THAT THE AMENDMENTS WILL
HAVE ON THIS BILL. AS IN
PARTICULAR FOR COUNTY OFFICES
WE BELIEVE THAT WE WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THE FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP PRIORITY BUT WE REALLY
SHARE THE CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED EARLIER REGARDING
PROCESSING. AND WE JUST WEREN'T
ABLE TO GET TO A POSITION IN
TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU TO ALL THE
WITNESSES. WHERE WERE YOU BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS.
DOCTOR PM. THANK YOU AND I WANT
TO THANK BOTH THE AUTHORS FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BOND. AS A FORMER
MEMBER OF THE STATE ALLOCATION
BOARD. WE HAVE ALREADY
COMMITTED ESSENTIALLY ALL THE
PRIOR BONDS AND I GUESS WERE
NOW RUNNING A LIST OF. PEOPLE
WHO THERE'S NO COMMITMENT RIGHT
SO HOW. THE TERMS OF WHEN THIS
BOND PASSES WHAT HAPPENS THERE
WE GO BACKWARDS TO THE TO THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN FUNDED OR
DOES IT START A NEW. WHERE
WHERE DOES THE- WHAT HAPPENS
WITH ASSUMING THE VOTERS PASS
IT YEAH YOU KNOW IT'S A- IT
WILL. HOW HOW DO WE PUT I AND
INVITED AND APPRECIATE ACTUALLY
DID MINISTRATIONS DOING SOME
PRIORITIZATION. WHERE DO WE
THERE'S A START WITH THE
BACKLOG GUARD IS THAT THE
BACKLOG OR DOES IT. START WITH
THE TIME THE BOND ACTUALLY IS
APPROVED BY THE VOTERS WE DO
HAVE EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A BACKLOG NOW SO WE
START WITH THE BACKLOG. OKAY SO
I JUST WANT TO KEEP THAT IN
MIND EIGHT HUNDRED BILLION
BACKLOG SO THAT MEANS THAT. I
DO APPRECIATE THE INCENTIVES I
WOULD ALSO. THE PRIORITIZATION
I THINK THAT HAVING SOME OF
THAT IMPORTANT I ALSO
APPRECIATE. THE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS ABOUT DEVELOPER FEES
ALTHOUGH AGAIN YOU KNOW WE'RE
TRYING TO BALANCE OUR HOUSING
TO I MEAN WE'RE NOT GONNA HAVE
STUDENTS WHO. DON'T HAVE PLACE
LET MOST OF WHAT WE DO HAVE
STUDENTS HAVE NO PLACE TO LIVE
AND THAT'S A PROBLEM. RIGHT AND
SO I THINK IT'S PRAISE SOMEONE
CONTINGENT ON US AND I
APPRECIATE. A SUMMER DOWNEY
SAID YOU CAN BE MONITORING THIS
REGULARLY AND THINKING ABOUT.
WHAT ARE THE SOLUTIONS WE HAVE
ASIDE FROM DEVELOPER FEES THAT
MAY ACTUALLY DISCOURAGE HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION. TO HELP SUPPORT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY FIRST OF ALL YOU HAVE
STUDENTS WHO ARE LIVING YOU
NEED TO EDUCATE THEM SO WE'D BE
SURE WE HAVE THERE'S- SO THEY
BOTH GO HAND IN HAND I ALSO.
WANTS TO SET A SAY THAT DIED I
EIGHT SUPPORT YOUR STRONG
SUPPORT THE P. L. A. INCENTIVES
I THINK YOU KNOW TERMS OF
THAT'S WE WANT TO LOOK AT
QUALITY CONSTRUCTION AND I KNOW
THAT PLA'S OF ACTUALLY
GENERATED MORE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR PEOPLE HERE AND AT LEAST IN
MY DISTRICT SO. I JUST I KNOW
THAT WAS RAISED BY SOME
OPPOSITION ABOUT THAT AND THEN
FINALLY I THINK IN TERMS OF THE
HIGHER EDUCATION PIECE I THINK
I'VE SAID THIS BEFORE IN THE
COMMITTEE CERTAINLY VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT'S IN THIS
PLAN FOR HIGHER EDUCATION. BUT
IN THE SAME IN SOME SENSES WE
NEED TO COME OF THE MORE
SYSTEMATIC WAY OF ALSO FOUND
CUT AND WE'RE SO FAR BEHIND
THAT'S WHAT WE DID YOU KNOW WE
NEED THIS BECAUSE WE ARE SO FAR
BEHIND IN ALL OR THREE SYSTEMS
I. YOU KNOW WHAT THAT ARE YOU
SEE. AT A CSU AND OF COURSE
KEOGH COMMITTEE COLLEGE
DISTRICT. SO WHILE CERTAINLY
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT. I THINK
WE NEED TO LOOK MORE
SYSTEMATICALLY BECAUSE I THINK
THE LAST HIGHER EDUCATION BONDS
HOW LONG AGO. CENTER LATER. TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX OKAY SUCH A
LONG TIME AGO SO. WE NEED TO.
ALSO TH EVEN THAT AFTER HE
PASSED THE SPOT WE NEED TO
THINK HOW WE DO THAT MORE
SYSTEMATICALLY IN SOME COULD
ARGUE ALSO THAT LITTLE BIT OF
K. TWELVE PASSED YOU MORE BONDS
BUT- THINKING ABOUT. MORE
SYSTEMATICALLY FUNDING OUR
CAPITAL PROJECTS WITH THAT. I
THINK IS NECESSARY VERY MUCH.
MANAGER GET CAN I JUST COME IN
YOUR MANAGER YES. TO PANIC
GOING FORWARD I'D BE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOUNGER SENATOR
GLAZERS WELL. TO LOOK AT OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION FUNDING MODEL
FOR IT FOR THEIR FACILITIES.
AND ALSO HOW IT'S APPLIED
ACROSS THE SYSTEM AND EVEN ON
EACH CAMPUS. I WALK THROUGH
CAMPUS JUST ABOUT EVERY DAY.
BOBBI STAY WHEN I'M AT HOME
WITH THE DOG IN THE MORNING I.
C. LE DISPARITY THERE SEE
BUILDINGS THAT ARE. BRAND NEW
SHINY. AND WHILE THAT DIDN'T
SEEM TO ME THAT HAS THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY AND THEN OTHERS ARE.
IN THE CLASSROOMS AND LOOK THE
SAME WAY THEY DID WHEN I WAS
THERE THIRTY FIVE. THIRTY YEARS
AGO WHATEVER WAS. THIRTY YEARS
AGO SO I'M I THINK THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS WAS WORTHY OF
DISCUSSION. MY RESPONSE. THE
LAST ADMINISTRATION REALLY
BROKE WITH TRADITION. AND
RATHER THAN FOCUSING ON THESE
TYPES OF CAPITAL BOND
SYSTEMATICALLY OVERTIME. OR IN
THE OLD DAYS THE OLD COPY FUND.
WHICH WAS OIL. REVENUE THEY
RELIED UPON INTERNAL BORROWING.
THAT WILL. WAS IF IT WAS TO
CONTINUE PUT PRESSURE ON
TUITION INCREASES AND IT WAS
SOMETHING I WAS VERY MUCH
OPPOSED TO DURING THAT TIME AND
SO WE HAD KIND OF A FREEZE. BUT
I THINK YOU'RE YOUR COMMENTS
ARE WELL TAKEN AND I WOULD
SUPPORT CONTINUING WORK ON THAT
AREA. THANK YOU BOTH CENTER
DRAWS SO YEAH I'M- THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON THIS AND I
THINK THE THINGS THAT YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED HERE FOR THE FOR THE
USE OF THE OF THE FUNDS IS A
REALLY GREAT THINGS THAT HE
PROBABLY WOULD NEVER HAVE SEEN
IN THE IN THE PAST. BUT THERE'S
SO MANY THINGS I WONDER IN HOW
DO YOU GIVE GUIDANCE AND FOCUS
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MANY THINGS
YOU TRYING TO TRYING TO ADDRESS
PRESCHOOLS WHICH I THINK IS
GREAT WE NOW HAVE WE'RE GONNA
HAVE THE NEED FOR MORE SPACE
FOR PRESCHOOL WITH SUCH A SUCH
A FOCUS THERE. BUT ALSO HEALTH
AND SAFETY STUDENT HOUSING ON
DISASTER ASSISTANCE THERE'S SO
MANY SO MANY THINGS HOW DO YOU
REALLY ARE YOU REALLY GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF HAVING AN IMPACT
WHEN IT SPREAD OUT IN SO MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS. WELL FIRST WHAT
IS YOUR HAS TO HAVE THE- RIGHT
THE PROGRAM IS STILL BASED ON
NEED THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT IT'S
NOT JUST GET I GET I GET MY
SHARE ITS NEED THEY HAVE TO
ESTABLISH A TO BE HARD TO WRITE
WILL HAVE TO ESTABLISH A NEED
AND IT'S VERY TECHNICAL
PROCESS. THEY ALSO HAVE TO WANT
THE MONEY AND SO THOSE TWO
THINGS HAVE TO HAPPEN IN THIS
WHOLE PROCESS I WOULD SAY
PRETTY EQUITABLE PROCESS SET UP
TO THE STATE ALLOCATION BOARD
BOARD THAT WE SIT ON THAT THAT
THAT DOLES OUT THE MONEY FOR
SCHOOLS FROM THE BOND AND ALSO
SETS UP THE ASSOCIATE
REGULATIONS. TO ENSURE THAT
THAT MONEY IS DEL VALLE WISELY
FAIRLY. AND AS RAPIDLY AS
POSSIBLE. IN IN THE IN THE
HIGHER EDUCATION SPACE BILL
SYSTEMS HAVE FIVE YEAR CAPITAL
PLANS TO TRY TO SET PRIORITIES.
TO PUBLIC HEARINGS AND PUBLIC
DEBATE. AND THAT PROBABLY WOULD
BE THE GUIDANCE THAT THEY WOULD
USE GOING FORWARD IF THE BOND
IS APPROVED TO. MAKE GOOD
CHOICES THAT GOING FORWARD. THE
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. WE
HAVE A MOTION. BILLS REMOVED
JOHN WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
SAYS FOR AN IPHONE I THINK
SENATOR GLAZER AND OTHERS THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR WORKING
TOGETHER IN A- STAKEHOLDERS TO
PUT THIS TOGETHER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR PAM AND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM ONE AB FORTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS THAT THE MEASURE BE
RETURNED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
FOR CONSIDERATION LEYVA. LEYVA
I WILL WRITE WILK I CHIANG
RUSSELL. RUSSELL AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
PAN HI CAN I. THANK YOU. RIGHT
THAT BILL IS OUT SIX ZERO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED